years has gone by and where are
we to be
frank we're kneep in
Bull is where we
are everyone who held a key position in
the military still has that position or
has been promoted John Kirby still sits
on his perch Lincoln continues to delay
key evidence By ignoring delay or
delaying
subpoenas not a single General SLA down
their Stars not a single person has been
held accountable are so called leader
can't seem to even utter their names in
public not even once a broken heart and
righteous Anger from a father who lost
his son Lance corporal Jared schmidtz
due to Biden's disastrous withdrawal
from Afghanistan now that travesty cost
the lives of 13 American Service members
and of course the same players who
screwed up in Afghanistan Kirby and
blinkin including are now running the
show in yet another Middle East crisis
with the lives of us hostages on the
line hostages uh in Jeopardy if there is
a ground invasion you want to make a
speech no look obviously they're in
Jeopardy the question is whether or not
there's any way of getting them out and
if we get them out we should get them
out it's not just the 10 unaccounted for
Americans reports tonight that the Biden
Administration is prepping for the mass
evacuation of hundreds of thousands of
Americans throughout the Middle East
joining me now is that Goldstar dad you
just heard a moment ago Mark Schmidt
Schmid's Mark um
first of all it's it's really good to
see you tonight thank you for joining us
how much Faith do you have in that same
Biden team as you're watching this
unfold in the Middle East as dangerous
as this situation
is I have no faith in them I don't think
they've learned a single lesson from
Afghanistan I mean we still have
American citizens in Afghanistan that we
haven't gotten out I just wonder if
blinkin is now climbing in the perch of
uh Kirby where he saw no no chaos you
know you know it I think these guys are
just toned up I think sometimes the um
state department needs to take a
backseat instead of trying to lead the
action here they they need to to figure
out what the hell they're doing because
they they seem to screw up everything
well Mark I've never seen a situation
where people can screw up more and yet
there's no accountability there's no
change in policy and there's no
accountability no change in Personnel I
mean if this were a basketball team with
a coach and an assistant coach that kept
losing the whole coaching staff would be
fired but not
here it seems this is probably the
safest job in the world to have next to
being a meteorologist you know where you
get to be wrong half the time and still
have your job I mean it these guys um
unfortunately have not taken much from
the history books and learned from from
that and I'm speaking specifically to
Afghanistan you know they uh We've
demanded for resignations gotten none we
um we're seeing uh generals retiring out
and they're not done we're not done with
them we'll be calling them back in to
the Foreign Affairs committee to still
answer a lot of questions that they may
have think thought that they gotten away
from without having an answer to but
there's still a lot to to be done and um
we're never going to stop now Mark I
want you to see this exchange that
secretary blinkin had about the status
of the hostages do you believe that all
10 uncounted for Americans are being
held
hostage uh Christen we don't know we
don't know for sure is whether some of
the um unaccounted for are dead and have
simply not been uncovered yet or whether
the hostage but we we have a pretty
strong idea that some number of the 10
at least are being held in in Gaza by
Hamas I mean Mark does anyone on the
face of the planet look at that
interview and his comments and think
this guy knows what he's doing anyone
alive not at all not at all you know and
I I fear here for those families that
are concerned for their loved ones still
over there um I know our military at the
drop of a hat would do what they've got
to do and what they love to do Best But
the last thing I want to see is another
Gold Star Family out of all this um you
know this I don't think a lot of this
stuff would have happened including
Ukraine and many other instances that
are going on around the world have we
had a leader that actually showed some
backbone I've been watching his idle
threats to to Iran that if you do this
we're going to do that you know I don't
see anybody being spooked by that
whatsoever um well no it's shameful it's
Mark um thank you and we continue to
pray for you your family and the
families of all those service members
lost thank you so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else